we've got some great audience questions
this week remember you can submit your
audience questions by submitting an
email at david pakman.com on the contact
form first question this week
hey David what's the worst thing you've
seen someone do on public transportation
ah you know it's there's a lot of really
horrible things I've seen on public
transportation I don't even know if
you're in aiding on the subway even
counts because it's such a frequent
thing now in big cities that it barely
even warrants a mention you know it's
like I've just the urination outside and
right and even inside at this point
doesn't even faze me in any way
defecation I've not seen in that that
may be a different story one of the
worst incidents I experienced was
actually a guy collecting his mucus and
it sounds bonkers and it is there was a
guy and former producer Lewis was
actually on on the train with me when
this happened there was a guy with a
plastic bag collecting his mucus and I
don't I mean it's it's vile and gross
there was clearly mental illness at play
but it was probably the most horrible
thing I saw on public transit and then
beyond that I've but I've experienced
just people who smell really really bad
and you would think oh you know homeless
people don't have a place to shower
these did not appear to be homeless
people it was people who just seemed to
not shower and just have absolutely
rancid body odor and you know they might
I know that there's a medical condition
that makes body odor particularly bad
it's possible that they had that I'm not
making fun of anybody but those were
some of the worst experiences I've had
yeah for me I remember seeing a guy I
forget what city it was just passed out
resting on two seats okay and his own
vomit was partially on himself yeah also
on the ground of the subway and the
worst part about that is every time the
subway moves you know and comes to a
complete stop the puke would slide
across the subway gr yeah and so you'd
have to like move around to try to avoid
it that was pretty bad
yeah that sounds pretty bad I've not
actually seen some of the really bad
stories that some people have talked
about my girlfriend was once attacked by
another woman who for whatever reason
didn't seem to
like her and it was sort of giving her
the evil eye for a while on a bus and
when they got off the woman came over
from about 20 feet away and just opened
an umbrella right into her face
whoa and then closed it and walked away
and a couple people came over and said
that that woman did that on purpose and
everybody was just so dazed that that
nothing happened and that was that but
again that's not it's it's bad but it's
not like something so crazy that is
unbelievable right I mean these things
happen on public transit I guess or at
least I've been told technically an
assault it sure your girlfriend was fine
from that and I think an umbrella
getting you know getting a little bit
too bad yeah oh really lip yeah yeah
yeah it was I'm gonna ask if you had
seen any fights on public transit
because some close calls just the other
day I actually had at Downtown Crossing
in Boston
there was a very elderly woman walking
down the stairs to get down to the
redline and there were two people
helping her and as a result of this they
were blocking the full width of the
stairs now
certainly they probably should have used
the elevator but they weren't okay
elderly lady is being helped down a big
crowd starts to form and one guy starts
yelling yelling yelling saying go go go
another guy takes a fence and says
there's an old lady stop pushing stop
pushing those two guys start to escalate
into what becomes almost a fight and
it's just a misunderstanding right the
guy yelling to go didn't know that there
was an elderly lady the guy yelling
there's an elderly lady didn't realize
that the other guy probably had a bad
day and was just trying to get to the
subway whatever so we get to the actual
platform and they both take off their
jackets which is of course what you do
when you're getting ready to fight um
and they start saying well I'm right
here and the other guy goes right I'm
right here
and it's basically one of these
situations where neither wants to be
perceived as backing away from the fight
but at the same time neither of them
really wants to actually fight so they
both just make it clear that they're
there and if the other guy wants to
start the fight they will be there to
defend themselves but it's also clear
that they don't really want to fight it
and it was just a lot of yelling no
physical contact and then this little
immigrant Hispanic
I comes over and stands in between the
two of them and this guy is half the
size of both of these guys and says guys
it was a misunderstanding it was a
misunderstanding but you guys don't want
to you don't you don't want to you don't
want to do this and it actually
de-escalated the entire thing and I
ended up talking to that guy and just
out of curiosity asking him where he's
from he was from Peru you know the long
story that guy actually ended up
breaking up what was potentially a fight
that nobody really wanted to have and
then the old lady you caused all this
commotion had no idea knocked out
everyone right that's how it ended she
had no idea she had no idea what was
going on at that her presence even
caused cause the problem